SOUNDING THE ALARM ABOUT A SURGE
IN BORDER CROSSINGS ON AMERICA'S
SOUTHER BORDER.
>> LOOK AT ALL THE PAPERS.
EVERY SINGLE ONE IS A LIFE.
>> Reporter: THIS SISTER VISITS
MIGRANTS IN MEXICO EVERY WEEK
WHERE SHE SAYS MORE THAN 7,000
OF THE TENS OF THOUSANDS ALONG
THE ENTIRE BORDER U.S. OFFICIALS
SAY HAVE BEEN WAITING.
>> MORE THAN SEVEN MONTHS?
>> Reporter: FOR THE LIFTING OF
TITLE 42.
>> MORE THAN EIGHT MONTHS.
>> Reporter: THAT'S THE PANDEMIC
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER SET TO END
NEXT MONTH.
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS, TITLE 42
HAS ALLOWED U.S. IMMIGRATION
AGENTS TO SWIFTLY EXPEL MORE
THAN 1.7 MILLION MIGRANTS TO
MEXICO, INCLUDING EVERYONE HERE.
THIS WOMAN FROM GUATEMALA.
SHE ASKED US TO CALL HER SANDY
AND NOT SHOW HER FACE BECAUSE
SHE'S FLEEING VIOLENCE.
AFTER TWO MEMBERS OF HER FAMILY
WERE KILLED.
SANDY SAYS SHE PRAISED GOD WHEN
SHE MADE IT TO THE U.S. BECAUSE
SHE AND HER 8-YEAR-OLD SON
NEARLY SUFFOCATED.
SHE SAYS AT SOME POINT PEOPLE
WERE PASSING OUT.
IN THE TRACTOR-TRAILER THEY
TRAVELED IN TO REACH THE BORDER.
SHE SAYS SHE WAS SWIFTLY
RETURNED TO MEXICO BY U.S.
IMMIGRATION AGENTS TO A
KIDNAPPING HOT SPOT.
WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF?
THEY ALL SAY THAT THEY ARE
AFRAID OF KIDNAPPING.
SINCE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN OFFICE,
HUMAN RIGHTS FIRST HAS
IDENTIFIED NEARLY 10,000 CASES
OF KIDNAPPING, TORTURE, RAPE OR
OTHER VIOLENT ATTACKS ON PEOPLE
BLOCKED OR EXPELLED TO MEXICO
UNDER TITLE 42.
THE MIGRANTS HERE FEEL BLESSED
TO LIVE WITHIN THE WALLS OF A
FAITH-BASED SHELTER.
CAPACITY IS ONLY 1,200, SISTER
NORMA SAYS.
3,000 MIGRANTS ARE LIVING HERE
IN A DANGEROUS PLAZA TURNED TENT
PEOPLE.
>> PEOPLE AT THE PLAZA ARE IN
DANGER.
>> Reporter: THE SISTER SHOWS US
HOW THE FAITH-BASED SHELTER SHE
HELPS FUND IS EXPANDING TO A
SECOND LOCATION.
WHAT'S CAPACITY GOING TO BE?
>> I'M HOPING IT CAN HOLD 3,000
PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: IT'S BEING BUILT BY
MIGRANTS, INCLUDING THIS WOMAN
WHO FOR HER SAFETY WE WILL CALL
NORAH.
YOU ARE EMOTIONAL.
SHE SAYS SHE FLED HONDURAS AFTER
HER DAUGHTER WAS KIDNAPPED AND
BEATEN.
SHE'S BEEN AT THE BORDER FOR ONE
YEAR WAITING FOR TITLE 42 TO BE
LIFTED AND RECENTLY SHE HAS SEEN
UKRAINIANS ARRIVE AT THE BORDER
AND SWIFTLY BE ALLOWED TO ENTER
THE U.S.
SHE SAYS SHE'S NOT OPPOSED TO
UKRAINIANS ENTERING THE U.S.,
BEING EXEMPT FROM TITLE 42,
BECAUSE SHE UNDERSTANDS THEIR
COUNTRY IS IN WAR.
AS THE END OF TITLE 42
APPROACHES FOR THE MIGRANTS --
WHOSE DESTINATION IS THE UNITED
STATES?
THEY WRITE THEIR PLEAS FOR HELP
ON LITTLE PIECES OF PAPER FOR
SISTER NORMA.
HOPING FOR AN END TO LIFE IN
LIMBO.
HOW IS IT GOING TO WORK ONCE
TITLE 42 LIFTS?
ACCORDING TO SISTER NORMA, SHE'S
IN CONTACT WITH THE PORT
DIRECTOR OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BRIDGE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
DETAILS, TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
CAPACITY.
SHE SAYS BECAUSE THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WAITING, IT
COULD TAKE DAY